[Music]
hey guys and welcome to another episode
of congratulations
[Music]
we're back with another episode my
babies what's up and uh you know how it
goes we got the merch
firing away
don't push me with the eagle
showing you what's up
right it's a perfect thing
for now right get it and rep the cult
don't push me and let that eagle soar um
and uh we're
off and running there's other there's
other merch too you go get the worldwide
life rips that's been selling out i keep
having to re-up the life rips tie-dyed
hoodie we got em all man go to
crystalia.com and check it out uh i'll
be in irvine on april and in april you
can go get tickets it's some of the
shows are sold out already so go check
it out
chrisley.com and uh i'm adding more
dates as it is and that as it goes uh
i'm thinking i'm doing a i just got some
offers to do tours in different cities
and [ __ ] so we'll see dude just go check
it out um chrisalia.com i'll be having
more and more uh dates up there and all
that and uh and that's uh that's really
it about that i have um
we have the patreon if you want to
support the show patreon.com crystalia
it really helps you get uh we we have
other uh we have an extra episode a
month and then we also have um different
things that we do like a whole other
show that we do uh called uh review mode
it's a segment that we do we put out on
patreon and then we also have behind the
scenes of the with chris videos there's
extra footage and all that [ __ ] and
discord and you know it's honestly it's
on and popping i don't like to say that
a lot but it's definitely on and popping
and um
so that's the patreon and um
that's it the other this pa we just got
done with the brea uh shows we did six
shows
we
uh it was crystalia and friends and man
it was [ __ ] so great it was great to
get back out there you know i did the
san diego shows and i did the oxnard
shows and they were great and the acts
just kind of like building
and i got about 40 something minutes
um that i'm doing um
and i had eric griffin out there
chappelle lacey maddie chimber
uh brit schmidt mike linochie and uh
maybe one or two other guys that i'm
forgetting [ __ ] whatever but oh brendan
schaub of course uh and it was just
[ __ ] great man it was really cool
everyone came out i mean we sold about
33 300 tickets so that's what's up man i
mean everyone was there and it was fun
we had a good time you know uh we we
took the [ __ ] uh van there we had to
get a van we got a sprinter van for it
we picked picked everyone up we came to
my house and then we went to the [ __ ]
um
uh brea
uh
improv and um
bro the driver drove so fast it was
unbelievable
and eric griffin was like [ __ ] what
is this mario card and i laughed for
about [ __ ] f i left for about five
five minutes
uh to think of that dude we were
bouncing we thought it was gonna be
another one of those [ __ ] uh what is
the uh tracy morgan and dude he was so
fast we were like we we basically the
the the ten of us in the car were like
we're going to get an action i don't
think we'll die but it'll be [ __ ] up
um but he was just [ __ ]
fast as [ __ ] we were talking about [ __ ]
the whole time
and then the the only time the driver
joined the conversation is when he we
started talking about fentanyl he's like
well you know the thing about fentanyl
is and he starts telling us about
fentanyl and we were like okay you're
going 95 miles an hour and only chiming
in
when we talk about fentanyl hey
be a better guy
you know don't be such a [ __ ]
mishap of a person dude he was going 95
mile no dude he actually hit almost 100
miles an hour we saw the dashboard and
then there was one time where i was like
hey man you know i mean look dude i
spoke up
i was like hey man we're not in any rush
don't even worry about it man don't
don't worry about like the way you're
going we we you're going real fast we
could just chill we're chill baby you
know and he was like oh man no don't
even he's like this ain't nothing man i
could he's like i drive these roads all
the time i drive this highway i know
these highways completely but but also
down man if you want also done if you
want
no worries we'll get there we'll we'll
go real slow and i was like jesus dude
that's like such a weird way to think to
be like yo
i know these freeways
i can go 100 miles an hour
traffic's different every day
it's not like these are like
you don't know what the cars are gonna
do though
pretty much freeways are all the same
right freeways are pretty much this way
sometimes they do this
and very rarely do they do this
but also
slow down because of all the cars that
do this kind of stuff right
those are gonna
and then we're gonna
and six of us will die
right
so just no don't worry about it i know
these rules dude that's such a dude you
know to be like bro i got it don't even
worry about it i gotta handle it and
it's like yeah but you don't though man
you're not orchestrating the whole
matrix
right
you're not jesus christ you're not in
these guys's minds
we're gonna die
we all die and we're all in [ __ ] hell
and the driver and we're just like see
[ __ ] and he's like well
you know it wasn't my fault man there
was some you know that what
like
i just uh he was going so [ __ ] fast
and we were [ __ ] ourselves and
that's it dude really i don't have
anything to say besides that
um but we got to brea and it was really
nice man and it was good and uh
we had a [ __ ] good time dude those
crowds were pretty bonkers pretty
[ __ ] bonkers
um
and that's it and then we drove back and
well friday i didn't like i had to work
so i was we did a video for um
on the on the more chris d'alia channel
calvin's birthday was he turned two dude
you know and he's like a person oh it's
[ __ ] awesome dude he's doing [ __ ]
where he's just like standing on the
couch and just falling off and going
bonk it's like so cute
and then and then like i laughed so hard
at it man kids get away with doing [ __ ]
that make you laugh that if anyone else
did it you'd just be like yo can you
[ __ ] stop doing that
[Laughter]
this is so annoying but it's just so
beautiful he's just standing on the
couch jumping off like i get mad at
[ __ ] mike linoche for the same [ __ ]
um
but it's a [ __ ] uh he we did um
so kristen wanted to
she had a very like crafty childhood
like her mom was always like creating
[ __ ] and like worlds and like lettered
like her mom would let kristen do crazy
like there was like do whatever they
want day
they had to do whatever they want day
once a year and she would be like what
do you want to do and kristen would be
like i want to swim from [ __ ] 9 a.m
to 8 p.m and her mom would be like okay
and they'd just be in the pool the whole
time and it's like bad mom but good mom
you know because she turned out to be a
great person but she would be like i
just want to eat cake for breakfast and
mom would be like okay bad mom but also
good mom you know once in a day you got
to let your [ __ ] you got to let the
people do that right it's why they it's
like it's why they give [ __ ] uh
convicts uh you know uh
uh [ __ ]
a workout place when it's like you know
they don't really need to get stronger
what are they doing because beat the
[ __ ] at each other but it's how they get
their aggression out right
so um
yeah she'd be like what do you want to
do and she's like let's go into
murdering spree and she'd be like okay
today's the only day
bad mom a good mom right it's like the
purge so um
so anyway uh
you know she took that with her and made
her you know it made her you know want
to be a good mom which is great and so
so kristen now is like wanting to do all
the [ __ ] for calvin which is awesome
and i got to be like they're also
thinking like about about how awesome it
is but also i want to be like you know
like life isn't always going to be like
this man don't get like [ __ ] so
don't think that you're you know it's
always going to be like this right
people aren't gonna always be happy you
walk into a room
right like i don't wanna tell him this
yet because he's only [ __ ] two but
like when he walks into a room it
doesn't matter who's in that room plus
he only knows like 25 people still
because of covid the first year of his
[ __ ] life he knew like 12 people and
that's it and every one time he walked
into a room everyone would be like
oh my god hi like dude like he's a
prince or some [ __ ] and so he's gonna
grow up and i gotta be like bro you know
just i don't know when the right time is
to be like yo bro it's not always gonna
be like this
you gotta you know you're gonna walk in
a room sometimes and people are gonna
[ __ ] hate you i don't wanna be like
that because that's what i always
thought i don't know what it was about
my childhood but like
i have this thing where whenever i walk
into a room i think everyone's gonna
[ __ ] hate me i think either
what they think is oh that guy saw me on
stage and doesn't like my comedy or
knows somebody that knows me that
doesn't like me and heard about me that
is and thinks i'm a piece of [ __ ] or
something and i've always thought that
in my life i need to walk into a room
and win people over now am i working
that out in therapy yes does it is it
some deep cedar itches yes does it come
to do my childhood yes was my childhood
great yes but did i have
microaggressions probably is it okay
learning about it
right
okay and it's all good my babies because
i'm becoming a person i was born the
same year my son was
so um
so in a way we're both too but uh yeah
so we
she was like kristen was like you take
him to the tar pits
and when you do i'm gonna redecorate his
whole room he loves dinosaurs calvin
loves [ __ ] dinosaurs and so
she was like okay her mom came out and
they both got to [ __ ] like it's not
even like they just paint they painted
it
they [ __ ] cut out dinosaurs she drew
dinosaurs on wood she cut out dinosaurs
and dude she [ __ ]
like literally like cut out wood pieces
of dinosaurs and then took those wood
pieces out
and glued them together to make a t-rex
it's like unfucking believable anyway
you can go on it you can see the more
crystallia channel uh surprising calvin
and dude she turned to her uh
uh turned the calvin's room while we
were at the tar pits seeing dinosaurs by
the way and the [ __ ] security dude
ruined it man i was like kevin wanna go
see dinosaurs he was like more dinosaurs
and he was like there's no dinosaurs in
there and i was like what's this guy
talking about what do they just have
what are they at the tarpon and i walked
in and i realized they have woolly
mammoths and saber-two tigers and [ __ ]
like that and they weren't technically
dinosaurs like there's no t-rexes and no
[ __ ] stegosauruses or ankylosauruses
but i'm like this security guard is
gonna [ __ ] like like he's gonna like
[ __ ] big-time me and be like actually
you know it's saber-toothed tigers a
different time period they they actually
existed with uh peop humans and
dinosaurs didn't just makes me laugh how
you saying dinosaurs when in actuality
they're you're going to go in there
there's going to be there's no diplois
hearts in there to be brutally honest
with you
and it's like dude okay but i'm with a
two-year-old right and i grew up my
whole life thinking that there were
dinosaurs at the [ __ ] la brea tar
pits and guess what it's fine i'm 41 and
i'm still kicking right
and calvin walks in he's just more
dinosaurs and now calvin's pointing to a
[ __ ] saber-two tiger saying dinosaur
dinosaur and i know it's not a dinosaur
because of the security guard and he's
saying dinosaur dinosaur and now i'm
like should i interject and be like well
dude actually and so the security guard
tried to ruin my day but he didn't do it
because i looked at my son and i only
realized that [ __ ] the only thing
that matters is love
security guards can't ruin [ __ ] not for
me not when it comes to love my baby not
when it comes to bringing my son to the
[ __ ] la brea tar pits dude
okay and so i [ __ ] looked at the la
brea tar pits and then we went to go
watch a 3d movie about ice age thought
it was going to be cute and then
realized there were rabid [ __ ]
direwolves trying to [ __ ] take down
woolly mammoths and [ __ ] going for
their jugular and calvin was watching it
in 3d so we left all good but we left
wasn't really something that a
two-year-old should watch
so we left
um
and then we went to look at more
dinosaurs in the tar pits dude it's
crazy how there's just like [ __ ] tar
pits in hollywood in the middle of
hollywood is where like dinosaurs died i
guess is what they're saying
ah
dinosaurs died in the middle of
hollywood
like seriously
that's what you're trying to tell me
like dude there were [ __ ]
brontosauruses just chilling in waihou
gay ones you know
just like roar
two gay brontosauruses just [ __ ] each
other
sucking their brontosauruses dicks dude
brontosaurus on his back no a
brontosaurus on his back and then
another brontosaurus doing it missionary
and the brontosaurus dick flopping all
over the place upwards
ah
that's the stuff i think about
got probs dude i never really realized
that when like gay guys have sex like
you could do it i always imagined it was
doggy style but you can actually do it
when the guy's on the back and then
you're facing him and then it's crazy
because his dick is everywhere right you
don't ever really think about that just
flopping all around if i do it i'd be in
trouble man i'd be knocking out [ __ ]
chandeliers and [ __ ] my [ __ ] is large
and in charge but it's all good dude
that's not what we're here to talk about
right i'm talking about my son in the la
brea tarp it's great cool great great
um
so yeah so we went to the [ __ ] la
brea tarps and then it came back and
calvin [ __ ] took a nap in our room
they finished up and then we [ __ ] let
calvin in and dude it's so cute when he
gets excited he goes like this
he's excited i want him to only be doing
that for a little bit longer though
because when he gets a super oh if he
gets older and he doesn't and it's like
okay well does he have a problem okay
anyway but it's awesome that he does
that dude it's so cute and he goes right
to the dinosaur book it's like dinosaur
book
and he goes out of blue he just says ted
dactyl and we're like how did you even
learn that you don't have to teach kids
[ __ ] i didn't know that
i didn't know that they'll just pick
[ __ ] up i'm a first-time dad i didn't
know that they'll just pick [ __ ] up
like he just was walking around and
saying oh [ __ ] i didn't know like i
never taught him oh [ __ ] he just goes oh
[ __ ]
and then he also [ __ ]
was trying to put something together and
he couldn't put it together and then he
goes like this dad i'd do it and i'm
like how do you even know
that sentence
so that i did it anyway dude talking
about my son too much um
but yeah it was his birthday he's over
two now and it's all good
rick ross ready for it right now
i'm ready for it that's all right i'm
ready for it i'm in central land and uh
hey rick ross dude you're so lonely okay
you were [ __ ] sporting a flame
thrower with some laker shorts on in
your house
and then you got the piano that played
itself and took a video that started
this whole [ __ ] congratulations
series hey rick ross you're lonely so
what do you do next
opens the thing in the back of the thing
i'm happy than a [ __ ]
this is dream come true for rosa
he bought a cow
i'm happier than a [ __ ] this is
a dream come true for rosie
this is for a young boy from carriage
city to have horses and now
a big boy addict come on down you good
you good yeah
[Applause]
oh my god
a kid a child on a roller coaster
that's yours welcome to the promised
land baby promised welcome to the
promised land i mean the horse is
looking
look
horses look what an [ __ ]
oh
them horses look in mind your business
so dick to his cow already
or to his horses
cow shows up and he and then he treats
the horses like [ __ ] and the cows like
oh i see my future welcome to the
promised land he's in a [ __ ] you know
an enclosed [ __ ]
it's like what like
you know a hundred feet by a hundred
feet welcome to the promised land hell
yeah one cow just now the cow is just as
lonely as [ __ ] rick ross hey rick
ross
get friends
i got a cow
sad
dude if i ever buy a cow shoot me in the
[ __ ] face straight up
if i ever buy a cow
shoot my face
shoot it a few times
you're lonely did you buy a cow you're
lonely
did you buy a cow do you sell meat no
you're lonely
you bought a cow
do you sell dairy products
no
you cry a lot
you're lonely rick ross
dude rick ross is his rap name rick ross
is someone else how hilarious is that
dude that's so funny he's not even rick
ross rick ross is rick ross and he is so
lonely that he got a piano that plays
himself [ __ ] sports a flamethrower in
his dining room and bought one cow
so [ __ ] lonely dude who are you
you're sad bro all good you're sad
maybach music
dude how [ __ ] i got the cow that
milked itself
i got the cow that milks itself
squirt squirt rose hey
that's so bad dude
oh good dude
my [ __ ]
i mean i can't what's the [ __ ]
where's the thing
no that's dj khaled
um
god dude and these white dudes just
[ __ ] unloading the cow like [ __ ] yeah
just no they know they think he's a
[ __ ] idiot imagine you're a cow
and you're rick ross's cow
right
god damn just tearing you from your
family and then you gotta go sit in a
[ __ ] stable outside of this [ __ ]
with a flamethrower and you're [ __ ]
in there
you're in the [ __ ] stable and you're
just inside you just occasionally see
[ __ ] flames through the window and
you're like there he goes [ __ ]
hearing the piano
i get the piano
i got the cow that milks itself
that's all right i'm ready for it i'm in
essentially
this dream come true for rosie you know
what this is for a young boy from
carrick city to have horses and now
a big boy addict come on down you good
you good
yeah
i mean
just say it's mine you know
you're you
yeah it's yours me
just has no idea how to speak english
it's an alien in rick ross's body that's
yours me oh no they'll figure me out
um
that's yours me wait what the heck you
mean it's yours um yes
[ __ ] vaporizes the people who heard
it
i got the cow that milks itself
dude he's got to get the cow in the
dining room to play the can of piano so
he could say i got the cow that milks
itself playing the piano that plays
itself
i got the cow that plays i got the cow
that plays the piano
i got the cow that milks itself playing
the piano that plays itself i don't need
the piano to play yourself no more cause
i got the cow that milks itself to play
the piano that plays itself dude just
with the flamethrower
i got the cow that milks itself playing
a piano that plays itself that don't
gotta play itself
anymore
happier than a [ __ ]
not tricking anyone but diddy
um
i gotta buddy that [ __ ] every time i
realize he's in the middle of a
conversation with somebody around me i
know
for sure
that the other person isn't
excited or invested about the
conversation yes dude
you're born
get better
dude he'll just corner someone with his
hands in his pockets just like yeah and
that's the thing about water and you're
just like nope no dude
don't get that my buddy's basically npr
bro he'll [ __ ] he's a rear naked
choco he'll put your ass to sleep baby
man you won't even know what happened
after the conversation you wake up and
you're like where am i bro
get
get more engaging he talks like [ __ ]
sing a little bit when you talk dude you
got to have some [ __ ] notes up and
down when you talk you go look at look
dude hi how you doing you say hey what's
up how are you hey how are you if you
know somebody that's like hey how you
doing oh dude sing a little bit when you
speak right
but my god dude i need there needs to be
this i i need to start a service
um
i need to start a service
conversation checkers
like where
you can hire my guys to come out because
here's the thing when you what's the
worst part about a party getting stuck
in a [ __ ] conversation and being
annoyed as [ __ ] that you had to talk to
somebody about their week and you're not
only never going to see them again but
you never even met them
right
oh oh this is a time suck for me i've
got to hear about how you went to the
dry cleaners and they [ __ ] up your
[ __ ]
and i don't know you and i'll never know
you again
this is a black hole bud
what a disrespectful [ __ ] you are
i'm here to enjoy my friend's engagement
or [ __ ] birthday and and you gotta
put me in a time suck
i'm basically one of those [ __ ]
uh cogs in minori report that just
chills
this is where i am now i'm in that white
water just chilling with two other dudes
touching my heads with their heads just
trying to predict the future but i'm not
even able to do that because you're
sucking my time talking about dry
cleaning
that's the worst part about parties and
you know it
okay
it's the worst part about parties so i'm
gonna start a new business called
conversation checkers
and i'm gonna hire people
that go to your parties
you can hire one to like 10 depending on
how [ __ ] big your party is
and they go and when they sense two
people in the conversation too long
they approach you and they say hi i'm
just checking the conversation do you
guys both want to be in this
and then you tell the guy
you tell the guy by yourself you rip off
and you say i'm actually having a good
time it's kind of interesting i didn't
know he went to the [ __ ] uh
australian outback for a summer and
we're just talking about that i said
okay let me check with the other guy hey
do you want to be in it and the guy says
yeah actually i haven't really talked
about my australian outback experience a
long time and i'm finding it really
cathartic and it's nice okay great
continue
or the conversation shows up and say hi
i'm just checking would both of you like
to be in this conversation and then one
guy pulls you off and says yeah actually
i've been going through a divorce and uh
it's really nice to be able to talk to
somebody about it even though i don't
really know the person uh it makes me
feel good to get it off my chest okay
i'll be right back sir
hey would you like to talk to the uh hey
how how's the conversation going and he
says man i don't even really know this
guy and he's just kind of like
talking to me about how shitty his
ex-wife is and it's
it's really a lot for me and i just came
to have fun at this party and he says
okay
uh excuse me guys uh gather around and
then gets the two people and he says so
uh i'm not gonna mention who but one of
you guys really doesn't want to be
involved in this conversation so it
would be nice if you just split up and
then you do that dude
that's a great [ __ ]
that is a great
uh
thing that i can
provide service that's a great service
conversation
conversation checkers dude
i'm so these people are so boring dude
everyone's so boring
get better at least do something
right you don't have to buy a [ __ ]
cow but be more interesting dude
imagine how [ __ ] boring rick ross is
at parties you know i bought a cow
oh really yeah
oh cool
so how do you know daniel
oh [ __ ]
i got a flamethrower
oh you do yeah sometimes i just walk
around my house topless
fire that [ __ ] off your boy at
it again
oh yeah
are you you work with him or you work
with daniel
y'all ever been in a room with nothing
in it but a piano playing silently in
the dark
by yourself
no
i got
that huh
yeah
i got a cow
did i tell you i got a cow
yeah how do you know daniel
that boy free in my
stable
sometimes the horses look at the cow
i tell them to mind their business
huh
boss
oh yeah
yeah boss
boss though
you could say it like boss
oh
it's like sauce
you wanna try
what
you want to try to say it
say what boss
but like boss
i don't know uh sure
boss
boss
boss
i got a cow
i feel honestly like that's how a
conversation goes at a party with rick
ross like how [ __ ] boring could it
[ __ ] be
boss
maybach music
[Laughter]
dude
[ __ ] man wow we make fun of rick ross a
lot in this huh
i don't know what old rappers do
like snoop dogg [ __ ] is a model for
gucci now i guess i'm done with i have
some gucci stuff
not again though snoop dogg is a model
for it they jumped
snoop dogg got a g-star campaign and
then a gucci campaign and it's like okay
so i guess i'm done with it
like
snoop dogg
just how many snoop dogs are there
that's [ __ ] in everything
i gotta [ __ ] chill though you know
dude i was in [ __ ] uh
i had a show the other night sometimes
people talk [ __ ] like people talk [ __ ]
when all my stuff went down people talk
[ __ ] like friends that i had would like
just use my [ __ ] for click bait and it
was so [ __ ] annoying and some people
had like tweeted stuff that was like it
was like i see stuff on twitter i'm like
[ __ ] you're my friend you've
been in my house like why like call me
at least like what the [ __ ] and they're
just making jokes at my expense and [ __ ]
and uh
you know now that i'm doing shows i see
these [ __ ] out like i see them
out
and like i'm not gonna not say something
to them because like
i don't know like i'm
it's not even like that i have this
mentality where it's like i know [ __ ]
it's like i just i'm gonna have to keep
seeing these people and so therefore i'm
going to approach you about the dumb
[ __ ] up [ __ ] you said about me right
like i'm not just gonna let it go
because i don't know what they think
when you like get
when the mob comes after you that you're
just gonna like go away and not come
back forever like these people are
[ __ ] idiots like the people that join
the mob and shame like dude
you know
now i have to see you so now what and
comics are such
[ __ ] [ __ ] like any time i bring it
up they're like well you know
technically i and you're just like dude
all right
so i was on the show with this one dude
that i actually like
and he said some things online like one
or two things online where i was like it
made me mad
and i was all amped all day i was like
having conversations in my head like i'm
gonna see this dude and i'm gonna give
him a piece of my mind and [ __ ]
the show was at like 10 and then before
that i had therapy i had [ __ ] therapy
for two and a half hours it was group
therapy with a bunch of different other
dudes
and we all go along and we check in our
stories every day uh every for the week
or whatever and we make sure that we're
being held accountable and [ __ ] you
know our addicts are in check and all
that [ __ ]
and they say chris what's on your mind
and i'm like oh well dude i got this
show later and there's this dude and he
talked a little bit of [ __ ] i like the
guy but he really pissed me off and i
can't wait to [ __ ] approach him and i
just get so mad and i'm dealing with
this [ __ ] anger and [ __ ] and i can't
wait to see him and just be like what's
up [ __ ] and they're like i'm
like but i know that that's not healthy
and [ __ ] so i'm checking it in with you
so like i [ __ ] feel
i feel [ __ ] angry and all this [ __ ]
and one of the dudes is like uh
oh so what do you want to do and i was
like what do you mean what i want to do
my therapist was like well what what do
you want to do when you get to the show
how do you see it going down and i'm
like i'm gonna i'm gonna show up and i'm
gonna i don't know i want to be like
what the [ __ ] bro why'd you do that [ __ ]
and they're like oh why because you want
them him to know why do you want to say
that because i want him to know i'm
angry i want him to know that what he
did was a dick and they say why
and i'm like
well because what he did wasn't right
and i say
because you knew and they said why he
said because he knows me and he was just
like [ __ ] adding to the mob and
trying to get clicks and [ __ ] grow
his twitter following or whatever and he
was using me and the [ __ ] opened
for me once
and they were like
well how do you see that going down like
what are you gonna say
and i'm gonna say i'm gonna go up to him
and i'm gonna say yo that was [ __ ] up
that you did that that's [ __ ] up i
know you and this and that and i was
like and what do you think he's gonna
say i'm gonna say
i don't know maybe he's gonna be like
um
[Music]
well either he's gonna be like
sorry or he's gonna be like
why the [ __ ] are you coming at me like
that [ __ ] you
and they're like
which one do you think it'll be and i
say i don't know
they say do you think that you'll get
what you want if you come at them like
that
and i'm like
well i don't know what do i want they're
like what do you want
i said i
i don't know i wanted to know that like
what he did [ __ ] hurt me
and they were like
well then why don't you instead of what
you want to do
why don't you just walk up to him and
say hey what you did really hurt me
and i was like
i don't know
they're like don't you think that that
would get your point across better
and i was like
like okay why don't you do that and i
was like
yeah
i guess you're right
but he should know that he was a dick
and they said
well if you tell him
that he hurt you
you probably have a better chance of
making him
see the situation and feel
worse than if you just came at him all
aggressively because he might just meet
you with aggression and i was like
okay
i guess i i guess i'll do that
and i did
i took what they [ __ ] said
and i went to my show and i saw the dude
and i said hey man well first of all he
said hi to me which i was like what he's
gonna actually dish it did it happen
now like i said i like this guy this is
not a guy i don't like
and uh i walked up to him and i said hey
man i just want to let you know like uh
you know when i was going after my [ __ ]
like i was having a really hard dark
time and it was hard for me very very
hard and
uh a lot of people came after me with
the mob and the shaming and all that
[ __ ] and you were a part of that
um and it really really bothered me and
it really hurt me and the guy says
what
and i said yeah you you tweeted some
stuff and it really [ __ ] hurt my
feelings man and it put me in a [ __ ] it
made it harder for me mentally and he
said
i did he's like oh my god dude no i like
to think that i don't do that kind of
stuff i i swear i don't think i did and
i said well i i i googled it today just
to make sure that you did and it's still
up and you did and he said oh my god and
he had to go on stage he did a good set
came back down and he said yo dude i i
you know i said that's a great set man
and he said yeah man he's like like i
like to say like i'm not that kind of
person that does that kind of stuff and
i genuinely don't remember doing that
but if i did dude like i'm really sorry
and i was like that's cool man i always
knew you to be a good guy i just wanted
to let you know you know
and uh he walked out and then i did my
set i did well i'm [ __ ] completely
leveled the place all good that's not
part of the story but
uh and then that was that and it went
well
so i guess i'm just trying to advocate
therapy you know you don't necessarily
have to have group therapy but it
[ __ ] helped man because i was ready
to [ __ ] all day i was angry about
this [ __ ] god man we're all living and
learning you know the second you think
that you have life figured out that's
when the [ __ ] goes crashing down i
thought i had it all figured out man i
really did my career was more important
than my family and everything i was like
this is how you do it man
and then boy did my [ __ ] life change
for the best and worst really did man
because now calvin's two
and i can't say that i had the worst two
years of my life i in fact had the best
two years of my life
because of that [ __ ] isn't that
crazy man
you know i don't really dwell on this
[ __ ] too much anymore
like i really love my life i'm having
fun and i'm very blessed man
as people say
um
blessed
and
i really love my family
and my friends dude
um
i don't know i feel lucky
i'm just glad i'm not this [ __ ]
lonely rapper out there buying cows
shooting flamethrowers and [ __ ]
bragging about my pianos you know what
i'm saying
i saw this guy [ __ ] at the coffee
bean i walk outside of the car i get
outside of my car i go i park the
[ __ ] bloody guts mobile and i get out
of my [ __ ]
car to go get a [ __ ] uh
coffee bean and i noticed this ferrari
next to me
and it's a it's a ferrari that's silver
and i look at it and i look at the
[ __ ] i look outside it and there's
this dude with shorts on
screaming spanish into a facetime call
um
with no shirt on
and just for shits i
well i know that the ferrari is his
because of how he's outside of the
ferrari with no shirt on screaming into
a facetime
and so i uh
i look at him and uh
and then just for shits i google the
weather and it's 59 degrees so i'm like
so sad you know
put on a shirt not for humiliation
just for health
you're freezing bro
and so
and so i'm watching him and he's [ __ ]
on this facetime and then i think he's
on instagram live and he's like yeah
that car is really fast he's talking
about his car and i'm just like jesus
the guy's tanned out dude he's so tan
he's tanner than his interior and then
he's got [ __ ] like he's like a little
bit buff you know he works out and [ __ ]
and he's just talking latin into it
laughing he's like yeah the car's fast
he's talking a mixture of la you know
what i mean spanish people they don't
just speak spanish every now and then
they'll throw in some english too just
to [ __ ] with everyone
um and so he's talking about how fast
his car is and i was like and i made a
joke with with the person i was with i
was like yo bro i was like how how about
how that would have been me if i wasn't
canceled
like and um
it was a joke but it's [ __ ] goddamn
you need you need to shake your life up
a little bit to realize what the [ __ ]
in perspective so do that do that
yourself dude do that yourself if you're
living wrong if you're living for the
wrong reasons if you're living [ __ ]
too hedonistic i mean i used to talk
about we're leaving that hedonistic
living that hedonistic lifestyle and
[ __ ] sucking and [ __ ] but dude
life's also about [ __ ] other stuff
too not just [ __ ] in sucking
[Music]
right
so just chill with your family man but
also you could do [ __ ] and sucking
but also chill with your family dude
so if you're doing that check yourself
man because if you don't check yourself
other people will man
take it from me
you don't want to be that dude that's
got the cow that milks itself
or just lost in hollywood in another
[ __ ] lawn order reboot you know
god damn it how many [ __ ] law and
orders are they gonna make i drove by
the other day and [ __ ] they got
anthony anderson and and and it's like
dude
how many [ __ ] law and orders are they
gonna make
law and over
that's it
those are the worst shows dude because
you don't know anything about the
characters
like has have any of those characters
ever gone home to their apartment to
their why are they even married do you
even know
that christopher maloney guy you know
when
that's a there's a guy who had a career
that just like how the [ __ ] did he
figure that how did he get that [ __ ]
going that guy's just [ __ ] loaded
he's got to be a dick right
i don't know him at all i don't know him
at all he could be the best nicest guy
in the world whatever
okay had to go potty came back sorry
about that um
for the cut but uh dude what about this
man somebody in the patreon you can sign
up for our patreon patreon.com uh 1
train 22 mixtapes is the patreon person
on patreon's name uh this strange
interview from james brown which i just
watched like 10 seconds of it i can't
believe i've never [ __ ] seen this do
it it resulted as a matter of fact in
brown assaulting his wife with a lead
pipe and firing a gun and a car that she
was in
these are charges that brown denies he
was released yesterday on fifteen
thousand dollars bond he joins us for
from atlanta to discuss the charges and
we welcome you james brown oh don't do
this
don't do any of it don't fire guns at
your wife also if you do don't do an
interview about it his lawyers are like
oh we really don't why is he wearing
[ __ ] sunglasses that go over
sunglasses
how did all of this trouble begin living
in america
so [ __ ] insane
there's nothing wrong
nothing wrong at all you're not in any
difficulty but you're out on bond no i'm
not
have all the charges been dropped yeah
i'm out of love
well
are you out on love or out of love which
is it i don't love
alone from night to night you find me
now james this isn't the first time you
and your wife had a problem the two of
you gonna be able to work this out let's
talk about some music you want to talk
about music and you don't want to talk
about i shot i shot at my wife but let's
let's talk about music no it's all over
well let's talk about your tour when are
you leaving we're leaving tomorrow
and where are you going
rio de janeiro and sao paulo
brazil
your fans will have read all about this
james aren't you concerned about that
caramuchi no
nagashan i'm i'm concerned because
there's nothing wrong
the most defensive oh
i'm concerned because nothing's wrong oh
it dude that was the bomb drop man he
couldn't look more like a grandma
unbelievable dude his hair looks like a
[ __ ] like the hiroshima bomb
unbelievable dude
unbelievable
dude
i'm concerned because nothing's wrong
oh my dude
and what are you going to say to your
fans when they ask you some questions
about it i'm going to say i feel good
papa's got a brand new bag it's a man's
world
sir plugging his music that's the second
time we've heard that in two days that's
very into now don't leave us james you
stay right there
how much does he fight tell us a little
bit about what you're going to be doing
next door
would you say
what are you going to be doing on this
tour i'm going to be doing papa's got a
brand new bag living in america
sex machine get up off of that thing
i feel good
jam
now i understand that you have already
i'm real dude
in the middle of it i'm
real dude you're really in trouble for
that what you did dude in 1988 you could
literally do anything in 1988 1988 you
could do anything in 1988 you could
[ __ ] go out on the street murder
someone and get away with it and then
like nobody had cell phones and [ __ ] you
could just
gregory peck could be a [ __ ] serial
killer and nobody gave a [ __ ] nobody
knew
this guy shot at his wife and then did
an interview about it
i'm sorry because nothing's wrong
ask you one serious question here i
understand you already have started
divorce proceedings does that mean that
you're now eligible oh no yes
i'm single uh i want amigo
you want to mingle yeah now the women
love you when you get out there why do
you think that is what did you say the
women love you when you heard it just
wanted to hear it again why is that
ladies
well i'm asking you huh
and you sing good and make love good
oh
oh she goes oh
well there we are we don't have that's
how calvin's that's how calvin sounds
when he sees when he when he realizes
there's another toy next to him right
he's playing with one and he looks over
and sees another toy that's what he
makes right there when you get out right
here why do you think that is what
you're saying the women love you when
you get out there why is that ladies
i'm asking you
well there we are we don't have to ask
anybody else we got that from the source
[Applause]
it's uh
it's
out of augusta georgia's ankle it's
drunk
joseph p young is the editor james bond
one of the advisors wow and we're doing
a fantastic job the second coming
it features uh on this week i think we
have the pope and um well you know i
believe the william the williams
brothers throwing up it's throwing up
and next we're gonna have revenant
shopping making it up
and uh we'll be doing a lot of good
things and hopefully we'll get
brother ted turner on the cover
ted where are you at
james we want to thank you for having
for being with us today and giving us an
opportunity yeah oh is there something
more you want to say that we haven't
seen a lot of things okay go ahead i
love america i love everybody wow wow
it sounds to me as though you're not
troubled by any of this at all this is a
man's world
thanks for reminding us of that every
once in a while
we forget get up remember it again james
good luck on your tour thanks for being
with us i guess we're going to hear lots
more hasta luego
dude
a dude the way at the end you know at
the end she was just like well that
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
this is mine
how's the luego wow he's five six i knew
it i could tell on tv how [ __ ] tall
someone is he's five six i said five
five
[ __ ] for comedy i get i i docked him
an inch but he's five six of course he
is shot has shot at his wife driving
away um could do anything in there 1980
you do [ __ ] anything
unfucking believable dude
wow man what a good one on our patreon
uh thank you for that uh 22 what the
[ __ ] was it one one tr one train 22
mixtapes okay um
[Music]
let's do some misconnections here we go
barista here santa monica you were the
polite man who came into the coffee shop
we ran out of creamer and you mentioned
you had some to share at home
barista here you were the polite man who
came into the coffee shop we ran out of
creamer you mentioned you had something
to share at home
wow is that a sexual thing yeah or is it
a flirt is it a straight up legit flirt
are they talking about [ __ ] um can't
ever tell
on [ __ ] misconnections that one's
very convoluted and pretty uh hard to
tell missing male friends
not a hookup just so everybody knows
right away it says not a hookup 50ish
year old newly bi
man what is that mwm what is
that man
well anyway whose wife allows him to
have a boyfriend okay hmm
so he's gay too or he's bi i guess
whatever looking for guys around the
same age to meet for coffee or drinks
i'm uh 5 11 2
201 pounds
bearish dad bod
nice bro looking for good communication
and possible friendship nice funny
east coast sarcastic not a hookup
so what's he trying to do he just wants
to make fun dude is this rick ross he's
lonely
do you enjoy cows
and flamethrowers i might be your guy
m for mwm means married white male okay
bearish married white male if you're out
there and you want to [ __ ] not hook
up with one hit this guy up
here's another one where is the woman
with the strap on
wow
it put a dash between o and n like it's
[ __ ]
why
because so it wouldn't get flagged
o dash n north hollywood where is the
woman with the strap that sounds like a
[ __ ] the worst children's book ever
where is the woman with the strap on by
you know
by some lady
um i used to come over we could talk
about lots of things as as you enjoyed
me bent over
wow dude
as you enjoyed me bent over
as you enjoyed me bent over
left the e out of over and bent over
spells everything wrong spells the
spells the things you don't need to
spell wrong wrong you know
uh
here's another one looking for that
woman to dress me up
north hollywood a lot of north hollywood
stuff going on right now looking for a w
a women i love when they do this looking
for a women i
love a women's remember that guy
from that guy i don't like mans no more
i love the women's
i follow him on instagram andrew c
caldwell unbelievable we like each
other's pictures i love the women's he
wears the craziest hats they look like
cakes looking for a woman to dress me up
in her clothes i'm thin and ddf female
only please siri serious only thank you
ddf down
what is that ddf i'm thin and ddf female
what is that he'll look it up
do not con so this is a this is a guy
that wants to be dressed up in women's
club man kinks are nuts
huh you know what ddf is or no
drug disease free
oh okay so i'm thin and drug disease
free female only please serious
well here we go looking for blues okay
what does this mean san francisco oh
there's gonna be some woke [ __ ] looking
for blues anybody got any going to be
around for super bowl what is that blues
is that drugs gotta be drugs not just
you don't want somebody to show up and
be sad like mimes hit me up
um emergency plumber oh you know we love
this one dude i love when they use the
plumber uh analogy
it's always like you know got an open
pipe that needs stuffing
got a leaky faucet i need to [ __ ]
stick it in a
here we go
experienced plumber here with the day
off looking for some cut pipe
any homes under 30 years old
we get it
hey guy we get it
any homes under 30 years old
means any guys under 30 just in case you
don't know looking for some cut
damn i need some cut pipe
experienced plumber with the day off
looking for some cut pipe
wow
here's another one farmer's market
norwalk
went to farmer's market bought some f
well meant to say fruit but says fright
and saw you at the papoosa booth
god farmer's markets suck you know
everyone's always like you gotta go they
got fresh strawberries and then you go
and it's just like they got like they're
selling like [ __ ] spices and [ __ ]
like you'd never buy
should have said hi you mentioned you
know how to cook zucchinis and i showed
you my bag with my zucchini okay so in
this situation
a zucchini is [ __ ] and bag with zucchini
is balls also with [ __ ]
they're not fooling anyone dude
dude would you like to see my bag with
zucchini
unbelievable oh here's the [ __ ]
instagram
where rick ross got the id well don't
don't hit that g wagon over there yeah
pull it right there so dick oh come on
not even close to the g wagon armored
ship
y'all got a delivery for the biggest
boss rick ross
okay
oh my god dude what you say you need
sure knows how to fill some space you
know when the guy goes to get the
package he just interviews the gardeners
y'all see that huh y'all see the boss
worst [ __ ]
id
i'm the boss i don't need
the
boss rose
i'm the boss i don't need id boss
so [ __ ] foreign
likes this guy dude unbelievable here
this id that's it right there driver
no driver license
no driver license i refuel
i mean obviously showed his id in the
middle of it you know cut it out
so disrespectful nah don't need id i'm
the boss let me [ __ ] up your language a
little bit
mucho gracia
for the motivation we motivating the
hustlers man
tell them to just drop that
come on man million on the pinky man
come on man
i should have started goddamn putting
some plants in the goddamn okay the
video's over you know i should have
started putting might want to put rocks
along here okay videos over there i want
rocks videos over man
come on man
come on man 14 seconds left gotta get
back to
devolving
devolving we gotta get back to nature
dude
everyone loses their mind let's get back
to nature eh
come on man
video's over
video's over man
come on
i mean dude we gotta get back to nature
bro
god how [ __ ] annoying would it be to
hang out with that guy god i'm really
blasting him lately okay well whatever
dude
no idea i'm the boss boss
okay yeah this is um
[Music]
i'm gonna lose my job no i'm the boss so
dick all right um that's it for the
episode on youtube if you want to catch
the rest of the episode it is on patreon
patreon.comcrystalia
not only do you get the rest of this
episode you get the rest of every
episode that has been backlogged and
also every month there's an extra
episode uh and you can all get get all
of those that we did backlogged as well
if you sign up today for just six bucks
and then we also have other things that
we do we do this segment called review
mode we have behind the scenes uh for
the with chris videos all sorts of extra
footage and we have a discord too and
you can be a producer on the show and
all that stuff there's different tiers
so anyway check it out
patreon.comcrystalia
thanks guys
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
congratulations
congratulations
[Music]
boss